wo der horizont weit die schiffe groß
sind und dort kommt er her und der
ostsee ein alter ddr kran tonnen schwer
kaum mehr in gebrauch mit dem namen
delfin 66 das war der zürcher hafenkran
in seinem natürlichen habitat im
rostocker hafen
im jahren abmontiert wurden nach nach
der wende da waren die nicht mehr so
gefragt weil der umschlag zurückgegangen
ist
wien
typen nicht mehr so benötigen
seine letzte reise für den früh morgens
am limmatquai große stahlteile schweben
in den engen gassen der altstadt neuer
vater des hafen krans ist der künstler
jan morgenthaler
er sieht zu wie die idee form annimmt
hat vor sich der roboter einen komplott
und hatte so angst
das rostige grün liegt schwer in der
malerischen altstadt sieht er aus wie
ein friedhof für krahn teile als die
kunst künstler und politiker geben sich
die ehre
wie aber passt ddr altmetall in die
putzige finanzmetropole saniert dann
nötig wie eine vorstufe haben
das ist ja es ist das traumbild oder den
ortes es in nrw nicht wo man es wo man
dankt das stimmt wie bei einem puzzle
entsteht aus den einzelteilen langsam
das gesamtbild eines krans
wir waren es mit schnee wie waren sie
mit nebel mittrage
mit schönwetter rudel vater summer mir
waren die verschiedene atmosphäre
klimatische bedingungen wie aus kosten-
und audi gewohnheiten wie man es mir
natürlich so alles normal wird sagen wir
ganz anders sie wie ist es so es ist wie
es ist wenn es spieler zu diesem spiel
gehören auch speziell angefertigte
schiffs poller die darauf warten dass
die ganz großen schiffe die limmat
hochfahren
berufe zum große schiff vor augen
seit die große hafen genua hamburg
barcelona
wir haben eigentlich das gehe um
definierten eine schiffsanlegestelle
oder ja das sind wir froh dass ich noch
auge felix objekte stellen das skaten
hausfrauen und dazu passen sondern ein
akustisches und intervention
zürich liegt am meer und ein hafenkran
hat das große wasser an land gezogen
es geht nicht um ich jetzt der chronik
und schneide ich einfach ein rohstoff
für sich gar nicht mehr ob es sich die
60 und was noch passiert
während der viel vor hat der trainer so
viel kraft des schiffes locken oder oder
das lied glück im vita horizont oder
hilft räume gefährden
das sind mir hat blut das auf rocker es
bleiben neun monate um diese fragen zu
beantworten